hey guys it's November 30th and with
Jess and chastity fully out of
commission it's up to me to pick up the
GS news bandwagon it makes for a pretty
busy day but when they can't do the news
it's somebody has to help son of a
[Music]
first up remember that Final Fantasy 15
boss that was supposed to take 72 real
hours to beat turns out it might be
closer to 1 hours who could forget when
conan o'brien played Final Fantasy 15
and battled a giant turtle it was a post
endgame boss and they told him it was
gonna take 72 real-time hours to beat it
well in an earlier interview with final
fantasy 15 director Hajime Tabata he
mentioned the battle would take around
15 real-time hours to complete wait a
second those are different numbers which
ones real well youtuber power pics has a
video on his channel reported by polygon
and it shows how to trigger the fight
and records the full process of taking
down the mountain tortoise the entire
video 50 minutes with a character level
at 69 he's using buffs and maxed out
combo attacks seems pretty crazy that he
could actually get it down to that
number he stated unless you go AFK for
71 hours there's no way the fight should
last that long so while it didn't take 3
real-time days to defeat this tortoise
it did take a fairly tedious fifty or so
minutes was this a miscommunication was
that dude way to buff maybe it meant
that it should take 72 in game hours
whatever the answer power pics received
50,000 Gil a trophy and an atom n type
bangle which if it does operate like
other Bengals it should increase the
players max HP you guys it's almost
December which means it's that magical
time of year no not the music it's time
for PlayStation Plus as free games of
December that's what I'm talking about
hate Christmas ease it
Sony today announced the lineup of
freebies that PlayStation Plus members
can pick up in December as announced on
the PlayStation Blog invisible ink and
stories path of Destiny's lead the way
on ps4 while hyper void and tiny
troopers joint ops are head it's ps3 the
latter also plays on ps4 and PlayStation
Vita through cross by Vita owners also
get color guardians and one of my
personal faves vvv vvv or as I like to
call it thatha thatha if you want to see
what vvvvvv is you're gonna have to go
back in time and watch Danny O'Dwyer's
playthrough in random encounter it's
good stuff these games will become
available when the PlayStation Store
refreshes for the first time in December
on Tuesday the 6th stop playing
Christmas music finally it should come
as no surprise that Pokemon is very
popular Pokemon Sun and Moon shattered
Nintendo's record becoming their fastest
selling game in America not only was Sun
and Moon the most pre-ordered game in
Nintendo's history there now the fastest
selling game ever launched in America in
under two weeks sales have already
eclipsed 3.7 million units that's an
eighty-five percent increase as compared
with previous record holders pokemon X&Y
over a similar period of time now it
seems really reasonable that these are
the lingering effects from Pokemon go
but Nintendo doesn't actually attribute
the success to the game Pokemon go isn't
mentioned in today's press release
though it seems hard to deny that
there's some kind of connection goes
popularity hit tremendous Heights over
the summer briefly boosting Nintendo's
market cap to be fair there was some
indication that sun and moon would be a
big hit it's demo broke nintendo records
when it was released in october and the
company indicated it would ship
significantly more copies of sun and
moon at launch than it did x and y which
is particularly notable considering the
increasing trend towards digital sales
what do you think was it hit because the
pokemon go i don't know you tell me
where my news person
well that's it for me today and regular
host Jess we back tomorrow for the first
of December no Joey one more Christmas
music its worst see you guys later
[Music]